changing the face of north las vegas as
a new development hopes to increase
revenue and better the community
meadowbrook is a small community in the
works right near gowan and simmons
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
has more on the project that's bringing
more families right to the valley
yes the housing market right now for
buyers is a really tough right now it
seems that everyone wants a house like
the one that you see behind me but
options are scarce
there is a new housing development in
north las vegas by bees or homes
with the hope that it will draw a good
crowd to the community
an 18-month process is now a reality as
22 new homes are being built in north
las vegas
and a new housing development known as
meadowbrook located
right off of west gowan road and simmons
street these single-story homes are
meant to appeal to the masses
targeting families in particular we are
currently offering
three floor plans and they are all
single stories
which we know customers really really
like
and they range from seventeen hundred
and fifty square feet and that's a three
bedroom two bathroom house up to
just under twenty two hundred square
feet the smaller community is meant to
create an
intimate feel the bigger lot size is
also a draw for those that want a big
backyard
something that is not typical of the
area north las vegas provides a really
really
good opportunity from a from an
affordability standpoint
we can do things like the lot sizes
that at a really affordable price like
we may not be able to do or other
builders aren't able to do in other
areas of the valley
eight homes have sold so far and they
take about five months to build
neighbor susie borland who has lived in
the neighborhood for 30 years
is ecstatic about the new development
she says before
the lot was just a wasteland people
would use to dispose of their debris
she hopes meadow brook will increase the
value of her home too
i'm real excited it's just something
bright and fresh and
exciting so that was just a desert and
to elaborate yeah a mattress is all over
people would bring their palm branches
and just throw them and beer cans and
you know they cleaned that up it made it
really a nice area
now as of now there are 14 homes still
available
and buyers have the opportunity to
really make these homes their own they
can pick out paint color
flooring light fixtures we'll have all
the information up on our website
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now